Nothing is going to bring back the feeling of your first Dark Souls playthrough.
That's the most depressing line I think I've ever started a video with, but it's the truth.
However, I think the remaster could come close, and here's how.
So the past few days I've been playing a Dark Souls mod that scatters enemies and items
not in a random manner, but in a calculated, well-designed way.
It's similar to what Scholar of The First Sin did but perhaps even better because
Dark Souls 1 was actually really well designed to begin with. This mod by FT Richter is
This mod by FT Richter is my argument for why the remaster should switch things up
and I think this encounter coming up on screen sums it up best and it's simple
I want that item the Black Knight is guarding
and usually I wouldn't.
Items moving around makes every corner of the world worth exploring again
and it makes skippable enemies worth fighting and a few minutes later
I realized that that Black Knight had spotted me on the next balcony and
had come to ambush me. It went on to make this fight with the Balder Knight unwinnable,
which led to me fleeing towards the blacksmith,
which led to me hoping
they'd fix back steps in the remaster. But, it was a new encounter in an old game
and that's what I want to play for.
Also the Giant Dad is in the forest and so is Oroboro. Those were good memes.
Now, there is a huge swath of people who say they don't want any gameplay changed for the remaster
and I can kind of understand that.
They want the Dark Souls they remember, and they probably want new players to the series to experience
exactly what they did seven years ago.
But to them I say: well, a new experience with items and enemies moved around
ironically is the Dark Souls I remember.
I remember going around corners with my shield up
only to get backstabbed by an enemy that I aggroed behind me. I remember taking stupid risks
for that item over there because it could be something amazing.
I remember crying out "Where the fuck is the bonfire?!"
after going through half of Sen's fortress tense because of all the progress I was about to lose.
Those are all things we experienced the first time we played Dark Souls, and those are all the things I
experienced when I played this mod.
So, ironically, I think the more they tweak the remaster
the more familiar the experience will be but any item or
enemy randomizer mod can give you those feelings, really. What made this mod, in particular,
special is that the changes have this really good flavor to them.
It's the little things like this hollow that gets crushed by the dragon when you enter the Burg
Or the bridge then always got bombarded with projectiles now having an item in the middle.
It's being ready to chill during the Moonlight Butterfly fight
then realizing that they threw a stone Sentinel on the bridge to slow you down if you don't kill it fast enough.
It's dying to the Anor Londo archers and then learning from your mistakes
and dying to the Anor Londo archers and trying to learn from your mistakes, and dying to the Anor Londo archers.
But then getting lucky and making it past the Anor Londo archers. I love it and hate it.
And i love it.
and there's actually a lot you can do from a lore perspective by just putting NPCs in certain locations.
For example, there was always two other New Londo sealers mentioned, alongside Ingward.
One alongside Lautrec and the other famously had her set
discoverable in Blight Town. Why not make her an NPC at the base of Blight Town?
And, the missing daughter of Chaos now guards the entrance to Quelaag
ingeniously placed between these two egg burdened who you risk aggroing
if you're not careful, during your fight with her.
And if there are any items they absolutely should move around,
it's key items and embers.
My search for the large ember brought me all the way down to where the basilisks are, where no
experienced player in their right mind would go again.
And I started to discover all the cut enemies that the creator had put down here like the butcher hollows and
these chaos hollows with the cragspider coming out of their back.
There's just so much room for creativity, and I hope the devs jump at this chance.
The original Dark Souls will always be playable, after all,
but tasteful changes to the remaster could make this amazing.
But all this said, it still lacked that feeling of playing alongside
hundreds and thousands of other people and that's why whether they change a lot, or a little
in this remaster, the remaster is still gonna feel damn good to play and is worth looking forward to.
But before I go on, I wanted to make you guys aware of something else and that's next month's Humble Bundle
where you can get Dark Souls 3 plus the Ashes of Ariandel DLC for just $12.
That's insanely cheap
and I think it's an amazing deal for those of you who want to gift the Dark Souls 3 experience to a friend or
maybe you're a console player and you're looking to make the switch to PC.
You can't go wrong for 12 bucks.
And that's not all, because if you subscribe before March 2nd you'll also
receive the other titles that they're bundling with Dark Souls 3 which are often these great indie titles that you should be playing anyway.
Last month for example had snake paths and Owl Boy
which I both really enjoyed and both received awesome critical acclaim.
You guys know
I only take sponsorships from companies that I believe in and
Humble is one of them.
Support developers, support charity vastly increase your gaming library every month and
support me if you click the links down below.
So where do you stand on the remaster?
Right now we're still waiting on a bit of information
so we could potentially have everything I've mentioned in this video when we could have none of it.
Personally I'd love to see them keep the game almost identical mechanically
But then go even further by shifting the balance of the game by buffing and nerfing certain items and spells in the game.
There's so many weapons and spells I'd love to try and build a character around.
Anyway, I bet we're gonna see some footage really soon, and I'll talk to you about it again then.
For now, thanks for sticking with me this month
My videos were recently disrupted by a short trip that I went on and then I came back with
really intense food poisoning and the bout of low motivation, but I'm back and I'm ready to go hard at it.
I love you guys. <3
This was a short video to tide you over while I work on the timeline video
that patrons voted for so I'll see you then, most likely.